the context I'd like for you to think
about is more - so this is um this is a
vehicle and um what more - who is a very
bloody war one of the most important
things about why we're so buddies
because death could happen on such a big
scale now the US Air Force they were
interested in making sure they could
save the lives of their pilots as much
as possible okay so this is on one of
the biggest bombers they've got and
there's this tricky thing like people
are trying to shoot down your your
aircraft right and so like your aircraft
come back in they're riddled with holes
from from an aircraft fire and I thought
be so they said look we want to armor
our aircraft that'll give him a better
chance for survival right so you would
make these things more lumber but of
course you can't just add more and more
armor to like an infinite why not
because they do cover higher right or it
becomes less efficient because it's so
heavy
etc so they're purchased of
statisticians some people would deal
with all this data and they said okay
can you work out for us
look at here all of the planes that come
back here where all the bullet holes are
can you tell us where we should put the
album okay
now interestingly don't wonder if you
can logic is saying to turn for you
right when they looked at all of the
planes they had the vast majority of all
of the bullet holes are so on mainly are
on the wings and on the end of the
fuselage over here that's like the main
part of the plane so it would it not be
a reasonable kind of conclusion to draw
on that if that's where we're getting
shot at the most that's why we should
put our long as it a reasonable kind of
condition
okay yes sir this is important right
yeah
as long as you've got the same memory
but I should be okay right except for
the fact that if you think back to the
question I proposed right if you think
about this you'll realize actually the
answer is exactly the opposite the wings
and the fuselage way all the bullet
holes are is the last place you should
put a thick thick big you already give
me some really good answers here what is
the sample bias that's inherent to the
situation if I tell you where you get
all of the planes that come back with
bullet holes
what's the bias yeah so we have a
special name for this this is where
triana love you to go and research this
later on this is called survivorship
bias very good so so a path don't tend
to come back without with holes in the
cockpit or in the engine block because
if you get shot there you don't come
back alright so those are the places
that you need armor so your bias your
sample only includes the survivors so
therefore it has a bias that comes to
does that make sense story would this
story the story was there were some
awesome mathematicians and statisticians
who said ok what you got to think about
what the data means and how to actually
use it